this is
the ramsey show you can be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show that's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
christy wright we are ramsey
personalities
uh we also have shows named after us
really creative of the ramsey network uh
we spent
tons and tons of sense and uh minutes
coming up with those names
but it's always fun when we are together
christy and i are very much in alignment
on what we are passionate about so we're
going to help you with your money of
course your money questions
we will help you with your life and time
and stress and work and business
career leading anything out career of
course well i say career i always say
work you know like you know it's like
you know do you want to do work you love
do you want to make money
and impact of course you do uh you want
to get that side hustle
up and going so all of those things
there
it's just wide open so that's a virtual
buffet don't you think christy i mean
there's a lot to cover there
we are here for you and here's the thing
you and i have a lot of fun when we host
together because there's such an overlap
between
what you do and helping people with
their passion their purpose
all of that and your steps and your in
your book that i'm so excited about
and then there's such overlap between
that and what i've done for years
business boutique of helping people use
their gifts and their passion
to start a side business or small
business so maybe someone right now is
thinking
i want to pay off my debt faster or i'm
just
itching to do something new what's my
next step you and i love helping
tag team that because the next step
might be a promotion a job change
it might be a business if it might be
both i don't know we're feeling crazy
today
people and christy and i both are very
active with entre leaderships
i've hosted those events hosted podcasts
for years so if you've got a leadership
question
yeah i've got i got two or three people
i got so we really are opening it up and
i gotta say this this is
this is such a squirrel moment oh i'm
ready did you have your ring cleaned or
yourself
you're so kind no it's the light they
just we have good lights okay because i
thought matt's like loving
i gotta show matt this clip he's gonna
be so excited so proud when you were
doing this a second ago
i literally couldn't focus it was like
blinding me
seriously i thought wow the way to go
matt wright he did
he did well but you know i learned i did
learn a trick it's not cleaned but um i
heard dawn
and a toothbrush like just dish soaked
on cleans it well make sure
so you know this is what people come for
this is more life advice here for you
probably not to clean your ring and make
a shiny but you know that cost you how
much
zip up that's right you've already got
the dish detergent took you about 30
seconds so this is the kind of stuff
that you come here for
no we kid we're going to have fun today
uh i think chrissy there's somebody out
there right now that's listed this
program for a long time
and it's scary to call in it's maybe
scary maybe they're scared of dave and
dave's not here so you can call us we're
saying
he's not here we are so much more fun
than dave but you were not so much
less frightening well that was the one
guy to be fair it was to his wife and i
she needed me to be fair he deserved it
he deserved it
all right let's get to the phones provo
utah is where we're gonna go to start it
off this hour grace joins us grace how
can we help
hi thanks for taking my call how are you
guys doing
well you can tell we're having fun
what's going on with you so
i am in college i'm 19 years old i just
finished my first
semester i'm really really lucky because
my uncle has a 529 account
that covers all of my education it had
about 40 grand in there and i'm going to
brigham young so it's really cheap and
i basically went in when i was 18 and i
didn't know what i wanted to study
so i went in going into mechanical
engineering and
because i was fascinated with it and i
failed out of it i did not do good and i
didn't like it and so i decided to do
something that i
loved and was interested in but then
which was
middle eastern studies in arabic and
then i realized that was really unwise
because it's not really applicable
in the workforce so now i'm
kind of lost about what to do going for
fourth okay let me ask you a question
that will yeah so you have another idea
that's that is kind of equally
fascinating than the arabic studies that
maybe is a little bit more
generally could be applied because i
don't want to leave the arabic thing yet
i want to come back to it maybe but i
want to know if you were getting ready
to tell us something else that you're
equally excited about
i love being outdoors so i've looked
into going to
the wildlife and wildlands conservation
majors
and the biodiversity conservation and
just kind of like the tourism there's
more tourism majors so
basically the outdoors majors are great
too yeah so also
in the air force rotc program so
anything i choose
i will have a career after that but i'm
also unsure about what to do
because i'm getting married and
my fiance has a good job if we move
around a lot it changes his income a lot
okay so hold on so hold on i wouldn't be
really wrong so grace you're
you are an amazing young lady you're on
top of things and i want to encourage
you for a moment that you need to relax
because you're 19 and you're just
getting started
and you're considering things that you
don't need to consider
right now now we know marriage is
happening great
but you still have to decide what it is
you want to do because there you know
christy could take over here i'm going
to give her the baton in just a moment
to talk about your mindset that what
you're dealing with but let's talk for
just a second about what you
want to do because you may have babies
one day right you may do who knows what
you're gonna do
but you always have this kind of urge
inside of you to do a certain type of
work
and i think before you make the next
wildlife thing or whatever you decide to
do i want you to actually sit and talk
to somebody
who's in that outdoor space let's just
call it that the outdoor industry
and i want you to talk to two three four
five seven
ten different people different positions
different roles here's why
when you sit with them and you talk to
them your head is going to get the
information
that you need it's almost like doing a
college term paper on their job
and then your heart is going to then
come in and go ding ding ding
all right that's what you need to do
yeah because we know you love the
outdoors so this is a great direction
but i want you to do that and stop
thinking about major right now stop
thinking about career
and everything i want you to just go
what kind of work outside might fire up
my soul and let me go talk to somebody
and verify that once you do that now we
make the education decision now
i'm going to turn you over to christy
because she's thinking ahead life
husband all that talk to her about that
well i can't
listen to this question grace and not
think of my own experience and i know
that my story is not like everyone's
story but my story is super common and
that is what i thought i wanted to do at
19
was different than what i thought i
wanted to do at 22 was different than
what i thought
i want to do at 25 and it's different
than what i'm doing today it was i'm
going to be
a business major i'm going to start a
business and then it was i'm going to be
in advertising work work um
working an ad agency in new york i'm
going to work in non-profit for the rest
of my life and then oh
i'm back to business and business
coaching through being an author and
speaker so it's just
an evolution so i just want you to take
the pressure off yourself to figure out
your whole life
at 19. yeah okay you're going to do what
you can with the information you have
today
but here's what i would encourage you i
love what ken said so what i heard in
your question there seems there's a
disconnect between the idea of a job
and the reality of a job and so i want
you to take your ideas that you have as
niche as they are because you've got
several there and i want you to go
intern
shadow explore just like ken said get
research talk to people
get as much exposure to those ideas to
find
the reality in them before you move
forward on the education
for them i want you to get the reality
of these ideas before you put more money
and time into the education
and you can do that through internships
shadowing researching talking just like
ken said
get more information and then you'll
know what to do next all right grace
hang on the line
we just debuted my new assessment the
get clear career assessment it's going
to give you a fantastic report
on your talent your passion and your
missional work that really fires you up
again you're 19. this will evolve but
it'll help you hang on the line we'll
give that to you
that's going to give you a great start
don't move this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague christy wright
and we are here taking your
questions to help you move forward
showing you hope through a clear path
to get where you want to and need to go
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
get to the phones and elise
is joining us in sacramento california
anna-lyse how can we help
well i know can you talk a lot about
finding a sweet spot
um and that used to really stress me out
because
i have so many um
like a lot of people can't even find one
but i just i have a lot of different
interests and i feel like i want to
pursue a career in all of them so
um so would it be advisable to
to like get qualified in one career
and do that for a little while but then
switch like just keep on switching
um i mean just like how do you live a
life that way i feel like
people never talk about yeah well yeah
so
this is not necessarily a problem i'm
just curious there are some patterns
here
yeah are we talking about three things
two things seven things 25 things
when you say that you've got a lot of
things what are we really talking about
well there's probably three main things
right now
but all these three main things have um
i've only figured them out in the past
few years that's okay all right so let's
do a little fun exercise
by the way so i feel like i have a lot
more discovering to do and i feel like
there'll be even
more things that um that i'm interested
in did you say you're 13
yeah i am oh 13. that's amazing i knew
he didn't catch that i was like
he's going to need to know this to
answer this question thank you you're
welcome i can't ever find the mustard in
the refrigerator either this is why
men need women by the way i i miss that
okay so
annelise uh we'll both we'll both
encourage you here
so number one you're um and 13.
awesome for calling in the show asking
that's so cool
amazing so here's the thing first time
i've ever called into something
there right now no no you're doing
awesome okay so let's have a fun
exercise
okay um i just want to know what the top
three are right now just list them out
for me one two and three go
yeah um the first is it's kind of
keeping but i want to be
um a general and an active so that kind
of like
hollywood um okay so we said acting
did i hear acting and then um and then i
want to be an aquarist
so it's like the zookeeper of aquariums
you like dive in the tanks and
and stuff like that aquarium i
i want to work as some kind of a
life coach or a nutritionist some kind
of um
advisor like with wellness and fitness
and stuff okay so
the aquarium cleaner the actor and the
life coach did i hear this correctly i'm
sorry
you got it all right so this is this is
a great example okay
so these are pretty broad and and their
differences between
between the different things really
fascinating actually but i think that
that's really exciting because at 13
you're just learning whatever you can
learn about those things because the
reality is is as as you kind of move
through life
you're going to learn more about
yourself and something that you're
interested in like
let's take the aquarium cleaning thing
might be boring out of your mind
10 years from now i don't know and you
don't know so
what's really exciting is that you're
thinking about these things here's what
i want you to focus on if you got
something to write with
i want you to focus on uh enjoying being
13
thinking about these things all the
things and looking into them always
explore them learn enough about them to
where you could pass a basic pop quiz on
what's involved that's what i would
recommend
in this season now here's what i want
you to focus on as you get older i want
you to really focus in
on the talent that you have you've
always been able to do
these type of things very well could be
a subject in school
could be a task a function and i want
you to just pay attention and always be
talking to people who know you really
well hey what am i best at doing
second question is what has always
interested me now this may change four
years from now
so we keep updating this list this is
not like a hard list that stays this way
at 13.
what do i love to do what do i love to
learn about what i love to engage in
and then the third thing is what results
do i really care about
and this is basically thinking about the
people you most want to help
and that's going to change too at 13.
who do i want to help
why do i want to help those people these
are good questions to have
in your tool belt as a 13 year old and
as you get
older answers are going to change and
get clearer and clearer and clearer and
there's where you get the clues
uh to what you want to do but right now
i want you just to explore christy
yeah i i love that first of all i just
want to say that you're awesome that you
have a lot of interests
you're like uh what the the bible talks
about the talents you're a 10 talent
chick
you got a lot of talents you've got a
lot of interest and that's a good
thing annalise that's going to come in
handy in your life and that's not
something you need to be frustrated by
or ashamed of or anything like that i
think that's so cool
the other thing i would say is there are
some of those things that you just
named that you could start to explore
right now if you can in your area
i don't know where or how if this i'm
sure somewhere in sacramento there's an
aquarium
but go go talk to the people go talk to
people that clean aquariums like like i
was thinking here in nashville
uh ken down at opry mills mall they've
got the aquarium restaurant
yes they've got the divers that go in if
annelise lived in nashville i'd say go
down there and say hey can i watch you
do it is there any way i could ever sit
in a little kayak on the top when you do
it could i maybe just swim around while
you do it
you know i don't know what they'd let
you do but you just hey ask forgiveness
not permission assume that you can
and and get yourself into these spaces
as much as you can go go
audition for uh acting in some small
commercial somewhere some used cardio
or just a middle school play middle
school play yeah anything
anytime you can dip your toe in the
water of these things that interest you
what's gonna be so
fascinating annelise is you're gonna
learn so much about yourself in the
process
you're gonna learn what you like and
what you don't like if you want to keep
doing it or if you don't
and that's just such valuable
information by the way that's something
you can continue to do
your whole life i'd give the same advice
to someone if they were 23
or 43 to just explore those things
before
uh you dive into them no pun intended so
yeah oh
well done christie folks she showed up
ready to play today
you know one other thing that i want you
to speak to as well yeah
is i know you and i are passionate about
this message annalise one other thing i
want you to hear just kind of a
philosophical
thought here is as you get older
and you begin to explore and do the
things that we were talking about and
your heart says yes
but your head goes i don't know
really listen to the heart be careful
with adults telling you oh that may not
be the safest
or the smartest path they mean well but
you gotta listen to your heart now this
is all assuming
that you actually have the talent to
pull this off i could have the heart to
play nba basketball christy but as you
know
now we're moving into delusion it's a
fine line
it's a fine line there between that
situation dreamer and delusion
where is the line i don't know no that's
such a good point and the other thing
that's interesting is because you're so
curious annelise at such a young age
thinking about the future
you're gonna know more at 17 and 24 and
33 there are people that call in this
show that are much older than you
asking the same question but you're just
going to have a head start
to know what those things are that
you're good at and and then the more
confidence you have the more you'll be
able to withstand those people that go
oh you can't
you can't do that you can't be an actor
and you're like really because i've been
doing it for 10 years thanks
so it's so true it's so true you're
starting early and then life hits you
right you've got these dreams and things
and then you got babies and you got or
maybe a parent with health issues or
you've got
all kinds of things you got to do and
you're going how do i
get back to this moment and that's why i
want to talk about a great tool that you
have we have a lot of adults that are
listening right now they're going hey i
want to get there
but christy i'm just trying to spin the
plates
i want to tell them about your free new
life balance quiz
uh text the word busy if you're just
feeling this right now you just need
some clarity and just
some relief that hey i'm not abnormal
but i can get out of this text the word
busy
to 33789 it's the word busy
text that to 33789 it pretty much should
be everybody listening right now
uh if you're going i don't know about
that it's a great great quiz christy and
also
i want to talk about the new book uh
it's right there on the desk for people
watching look at this take back
your time tell people what this
guilt-free guide to life balance well
it's so fun ken because both of our
books are in pre-sale at the same time
but we're only talking about yours right
now about various different topics
but it's about they work together
figuring out what your version of life
balance
is you don't have to live with this
guilt that's been nagging at you that
you're always doing the wrong thing
you can actually shake the guilt create
your version of balance and guess what
enjoy your life and that's what i want
to help you do
in my new book it's available for
pre-order and you get all kinds of free
bonus items when you get it
today ramseysolutions.com it's about
doing the right thing at the
right time it's such a bond drop i love
that
i love teeing you up to do that hey
don't move she is chrissy wright
i'm ken coleman we're here for you this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague christian wright
and we are here to take your questions
it is a free call
triple eight eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'd be thrilled to
talk with you whatever you wanna talk
about
life in general of course we'll talk
about money we'll talk about your work
we talk about your business we'll talk
about your time
we'll talk about cleaning cleaning
aquariums
we'll talk uh you know how do you chase
the thing while you're a parent
we both have interesting perspectives on
that as well
so i mean look we're here to help triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go to wichita kansas now amy joins
us on the line there amy how can we help
hi thank you for speaking with me sure
what's up um
i was calling to ask about business
burnout
i own a business that has two retail
locations
and i just find myself stretched very
thin
not knowing which direction to go i do
have employees but
not quite the revenue to add more and so
i'm just looking for guidance on
how to get everything done without being
completely worn out at the end of the
day
yeah that's a great question you're in a
tough spot with that tell me a little
bit more about your business what is
your business and who
who's in charge you have a manager on
duty do you have someone like that
that's each center's
um director or manager how does that
work for your business
um we have two gift and flower shops
that are retail so we do everything from
everyday
flowers funeral flowers wedding flowers
and i have two retail locations but
i manage basically everything i have a
couple of employees that are full
time and a couple part-time in each
location
um but it's still still a little short i
still feel like i'm the one
having to fix the receipt printer every
day rather than focusing on what i need
to focus on
and i just can't get myself over that
hump yeah
so let me let me ask you this if you
went out of town for a week
what would happen um while i don't do
that
let's run out this scenario here's what
i'm trying to do amy i'm trying to find
the problems is it a delegation problem
is it a competency problem is it short
staffed problem i'm trying to find what
are the problems because i want to help
you fix the problems
so that you're not burning out this is
fixable that's the great news it's very
fixable but we need to know what's the
true problem it's not the receipt
printer
that's a symptom i want to get to this i
want to get to the source here
so i actually amy amy i think you need
to answer her question
she wasn't just trapping you i actually
specifically think you need to tell
what would happen i want to know too go
i
i think everything would be fine for
those two weeks but it's the future
planning that would fall behind in our
business we have to plan pretty
seasonally
ahead of time and so for those two weeks
i feel confident that my staff would
have it covered
but if the lack of the next two weeks
then would things be ordered would there
be things
it's that lack of organization and that
lack of delegation
that i'm lacking and i feel like it's
because i'm so far behind i can't get
myself
enough ahead to plan ahead for those
things
yeah all right i'm just going to give
you something super tactical amy because
um sometimes
burnout is an issue of your emotion and
your your head space
this sounds like it's super tactical i'm
sure there's a there's an element of
head space but let's fix the tactical
because that's so fixable
i want you to make a list of your ideal
uh schedule your ideal job
responsibilities your job description
your key results areas you would define
it for yourself in a perfect world
what would you spend your time doing i'm
guessing it's not fixing the receipt
printer right like it's probably all
this planning strategy
the things that only you can do let's
say in your perfect world you're going
to spend
80 percent of your time doing those
types of things planning things
uh strategy etc the other 20 of the time
you know there's going to be fires that
you have to put put out and there's
going to be things you have to deal with
and that's what you do
as the owner that makes sense i want you
to write out that list now all the
things that you're currently doing
that don't fall on that ideal list i
want you to find a solution for
now there you've got several options for
solutions one solution is to delegate to
someone that is currently competent
another solution is to train someone up
to be competent in that thing
another solution is to hire and then
figure out how to get your revenues up
to be able to afford that person
another solution is to just stop doing
it let's say you're doing something
right now that's just stupid
and you're gonna be doing it you're
wasting your time doing it's taking your
time your employee's time and you just
don't need to do it anymore you're like
well let's just stop doing it
i'm gonna make up some exaggerated let's
say you write handwritten notes to every
order well that's just crazy you don't
have to do that just stop
right like there may be things in your
list that you can just stop doing i want
you to go through every single task
that you currently do that you don't
need to be doing it's not on your ideal
list and come up right out to the side a
solution
for that thing immediately you now can
see what you need to do how you're going
to free up your margin
now then it's going to be on you amy to
actually live it out
okay so that means that when you find
yourself
and your your temptation to micromanage
because no one loves it like you do and
no one can tie that bow like you can
to get yourself out of the weeds because
it's so tempting as the business owner
to get in the weeds because no one can
do it as good as you can it's your baby
i get that
but you need to be doing what only you
can do the business
survivability depends on it but i want
to give you something else too so
um amy we have our business boutique
conference coming up in october
it's october 14th through the 16th and
we've got incredible speakers it's three
days here in nashville i would love to
give you a ticket if you can't attend in
person it's also a live stream option
but stay on the phone we'll have kelly
give you a ticket to the business
boutique conference and that's going to
give you
that much more information to help you
figure out how to delegate
how to market how to spend your time on
the things that are going to actually
roi give you a return on your investment
where it keeps you in your lane of doing
what only you can do i know that that
sounds
so tactical but this problem is very
tactical it's very fixable
if you can delegate and get yourself in
the lane you need to be in i think it's
going to help you with that burnout yeah
and amy i want to go back to the
question that christy asked it was like
a searing
spear i hope you don't miss it she said
what would you do
what would happen to the business if you
were gone for two weeks and you're like
well it would be fine but it would be
the planning so i got a
suggestion and you can do what what you
want with this but if that's true and i
believe you were telling us the truth
then why don't you at least take a week
for a little vacation
and maybe half of that next week and do
some planning
and then based on the incredible advice
that chrissy just gave you
part of the thing that's on the list for
you is planning
and so if they can manage without you
for two weeks
how much better would the business be if
you spent
a good portion of each week just
planning that's right
and let everybody else do other things
so one other final piece of advice
i think you need to go get the beautiful
song from frozen let it go and maybe
play it in the car
every day as you drive in because
i think you gave her terrific advice if
she has that list and she really i'm
having fun with the silly song i know
but she's got to let that other stuff
go she does here's the other thing
though i want to use an example with
kids real quick because this just came
to mind
listen there was one day when carter was
driving me crazy he didn't like the
dinner options i put on the table and i
had absolutely had it
and i said that's it make yourself
whatever you want
and he said okay and that little child
this was back like a year or so ago so
he's probably five five and a half
he walks over the pantry he gets a stool
he goes over he gets the bread the
peanut butter
that i stood back in awe as my child
made his own
yeah peanut butter and jelly sandwich
something he'd never done before and i
didn't know he could do
why because i always do it for him
amy i wonder what your team members
could do
if you just sat back and let them yeah
and let them impress you that's a great
analogy let me ask you this follow-up
question
he probably got some peanut butter and
jelly all over the place it was a giant
perfect but wait a second but he still
got it
done he did it and he even cleaned it up
i said okay like
like it was not like how i make them
that's the beauty it was food that
nourished him and i didn't have to lift
a finger and that moment was so
eye-opening to me of
what else can my kids do that i'm not
aware of
because i'm just so busy doing it for
them and it's not that i don't want to
do it ken it's that it never
occurred to me that they were capable
and i think that as a business owners
and i certainly can relate to this
we feel that in our business going well
i've got to do it because only i know
how and only i can do it this good and
they don't know how they
and it's like hey what if you just let
them yeah and see what happens yeah and
as the business owner be okay with
peanut butter getting all over the
counter or whatever
and you know it's going ready they're
not gonna do it be ready that they may
do it better than you and you're like
dang okay i would have been thrilled
to hear that the rest of the story was
is that he like cut the crust off
and he had this beautiful little diamond
cut on it you're like that is how it
went that didn't happen
but hey he made the sandwich he ate the
sandwich and he was happy
and we both learned something from son
we're happy that's right
by the way i don't know if this is
coincidental or not
i don't know about you all in the booth
i want a pb and jake right now
i haven't had one in so long good stuff
carter can make you money amy thank you
for the call
really good stuff you got this don't
move more of the ramsey show coming
right up
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague christy wright
with ramsey personalities
she is the host of the christie wright
show on the ramsey network she's also a
number one
best-selling author her new book take
back your time the guilt-free
guide to life balance is available for
pre-sale
and fantastic fantastic stuff i host the
ken coleman show on
the ramsey network and my new book from
paycheck to purpose the clear path to
doing work you love is also available
for pre-sale
so a lot of people are saying on social
hey i can buy both of these together
because you got the
you got the discounts because they can
pre-order now the book comes out
later of course so a lot of people are
doing that so you know what it makes a
lot of sense because if you're going to
be on purpose in your work which is
everything that i'm teaching that you
were created to feel a unique role you
were needed you must do it
but to go for that look the reality is
there's family stuff there's finance
stuff
there's failure worried about all that
there's a lot of stuff a lot going on in
people's life how do i move from one
career to the next well
all that that i teach is great but if
you don't know how to
do the right thing at the right time
which is the premise of your book
and understanding there are seasons then
it can be really tough so they are
actually a nice little combo if i do say
so myself it really isn't i hadn't
thought about that because you and i are
so
when we're not inside the studio
together on fridays we each have three
kids and lots going on we're just
running so hard
but i got a message on social media the
day that your book launched i think this
was last monday yup
when it launched i got a message saying
uh because i'd shared it but it was this
monday i think it feels like time is
standing still yeah yeah
this monday yes okay so someone mess i
shared it you know on instagram
and someone messaged me i've been
waiting for this to go on pre-sale
because i wanted to get them at the same
time
save on shipping etc and then you get
all the bonus items but what's
interesting ken
is is one of the things i think people
may not know about our company ramsey
solutions and certainly you and i that i
think is worth saying
we are a company like as a value
as a principal we want to give you
a step-by-step plan in case you haven't
noticed that it's not a coincidence that
everything we put out
is a step-by-step plan because why
because if we just inspire you
and give you 200 pages in a book or 150
pages in a book that inspires you that's
great you're inspired for a minute and
then you don't know what to do about it
and so i've taken this idea of balance
and given you a step-by-step path to
creating your version of balance you've
taken this idea of a career where some
people think it's cool
to have a jerry maguire moment where you
grab the goldfish and say who's with me
and then you don't have a plan you're
like no no let's have a plan
that's right and you break this down
into your step-by-step plan on exactly
what you
do in order to make your next move and
so you can look at your path is it seven
steps seven stages
and you can see like even when i was on
the show with you the other day on your
show that can coleman show i could look
at that and see where different callers
were coming in at oh
you're at the get connected stage oh
you're at the get qualified stage
and then it makes it so clear because
when you have a plan and this is with
anything y'all
running a marathon managing your time
moving careers getting a promotion
starting a business whatever
when you can see it you can do it that's
right when you can see step by step this
is what i need to do you can do it it's
when you don't know what to do that you
feel overwhelmed and anxious so that's
why we do
what we do in the way that we do it
everything you get from us
will be a step-by-step plan and by the
way it freaking works it works yeah you
know you're right you know the fear of
the unknown
is to me the most gripping fear you know
you and i are both parents and i mean
you're
you're literally in it right now you're
in it right now with the littles right
but i also got three teens so i may
trade you to be honest with you i i
there are days where i go i don't know i
may want to trade but
um you know i remember when the kids
were little i remember when i was little
there
was a point where we all kind of get
scared of something in our room right
and we're like is that a thing is that
is that a person is that a monster is
that just a child thing because it still
happens to me oh does it really
yeah so what do you do you're like matt
could you look into that have you heard
my lakehouse story where the pyro went
out and i literally drove back to
nashville from alabama
because i was so scared true story kid i
am at the lake house i'm at the lake
by myself it's like 10 o'clock in the
i'm watching the greatest showman
all the lights are on we have a a place
on the water yeah
it's small but it like overlooks water
so you hear something or you think you
see something
the power goes out ken just the power
that's it
uh the killer was for sure outside and
he cut the power i'm sorry i did not
mean to minimize your fear
but what i'm trying to understand you're
sitting there watching the movie
and the power goes out yes and you say
the killer is out i'm going to die if i
don't get in the car and drive back
uh well there was a couple more steps i
lit a bunch of candles grabbed a butcher
knife and then i realized the terrifying
person in that whole scenario was me
but you still left and then i blew up
the candles took my butcher knife and
drove directly back to nashville so much
so that i
i talked to my husband as i'm driving
home he goes babe i'm a little concerned
about you driving at 10 and i was like
i'm so wired i could drive to california
there's no chance you were going to
sleep no the killer was outside i'm like
this is the part
with the you're in the audience you go
girl you got to run
this is fantastic so this is the fear of
the unknown
because here's the deal if matt's there
you say
uh you fix it yeah so matt goes out with
a flashlight
and he's like nothing's there right and
he goes and he looks but until we know
right that it's safe yeah it's the
tyranny of the mind oh my gosh and so
you're actually right about clear paths
when you can see okay i know i don't
know the
the specific outcome i don't know
necessarily the timing but i know this
is the direction
that's what we need many times to summon
the courage to actually move forward to
say
there's a clear path and if i do this if
i walk forward it's going to happen and
i think you're absolutely right
we need more of that you know in our
lives whether it be parenting
your marriage uh your your work your
business
your time and your life how do i get
control so
uh anyway great stuff uh it's it's
it is really really fun we'll talk more
about that later but you can pre-order
both of our books
uh ramsaysolutions.com all kinds of
goodies we'll talk more about that later
triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to
hunter in detroit hunter how can we help
hey ken hey kristy hi what's going on
so i
i love the like the place at work
i uh hello hunter you there
i'm sorry i got another phone call hey
would you mind telling them to hold that
we're live on the radio right now that'd
be great thank you i was like man he's
so bored in his job he's falling asleep
yeah we definitely need to get you out
of that work i think yeah
so the i like where i work i like the
ownership the management the benefits
are phenomenal the pay is good
i just don't like the work that i do
yeah what is it
and i'm so i'm in the machining industry
yeah so we would call that we've got a
should i quit my job quiz at kencole.com
and your result would be
you're doing the wrong thing in the
right place meaning you like the place
you like the people it's a nice culture
that's a big deal you gotta understand
that i don't necessarily like all
like most of the people there it's not
like uh
that's an important detail so what's
your question
um i'm just struggling finding like
like to get clear pretty much on like
what i want to do
i know i love helping people yeah what
who what
real quick tell me the people you love
helping most what problem do they have
that you love helping them with
just like any like
mostly anything like yeah
dig deeper come on hunter i know you're
one of the nicest people that's ever
walked the face of the earth i could
tell that about you
who would you love to help the most if
you could get paid for it
let your heart answer that just say it
doesn't have to be pretty what is it
so i love helping other young adults get
like financially clear okay now we're on
to something
there's a why behind that why why do you
want to help other people get
financially clear and stable
uh because i'm like doing it myself and
i
like want to see other people succeed in
their careers and their
like personal lives and their financial
lives
there you go okay so let's just pause
here we don't have to figure all this
out
okay but what you have to then do is you
have to say okay i know
the mission that i want to
complete so now we go what's the work
that i love to do that will allow that
mission to come to fruition is it
coaching
is it financial advising and when it
comes to retirement
investing uh is it teaching uh a
curriculum in a school
that's we have to figure out what's the
work that really fires up your soul and
then the final piece i'm kind of coming
backwards from my methodology hunter
is do i have the talent to pull this off
i want to make sure that i've got the
actual tools
to do this so here's what i want you to
do i want you to hang on the line kelly
let's give him my brand new
career assessment it's called the get
clear career assessment you said ken i
need to get clear
it's going to measure your talent your
passion and your mission going to fill
out a purpose statement for you
and show you professional possibilities
and then if you need to dig deeper
call the ken coleman show and we will
dive
deep but hunter you're on your way you
know who you want to help
and why and that's half of the equation
hey i want to thank my colleague christy
wright so much fun this hour i want to
thank our producer ben hill
our associate producer kelly daniel but
mostly we want to thank
you america you're why we do the show
this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsay advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast it's a quick hit of advice about
life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out
to have a conversation get answers about
life
i am ken coleman joined by my colleague
and
well you don't say fellow when i say
sister you don't say that either
fellow ramsey personality doesn't seem
right christy wright
we got to figure out what the technical
term is for that you know i know what
that means in general my colleague is
what i would normally say but my
fellow but you're not a fellow we all
know that so
we'll dig into that and then the next
time on the hour i'll just say that a
little bit differently we'll google that
at the next break yes
2021 chris you gotta be careful how you
say things
nice no not with me okay
i just it it flowed out fellow and then
i went she's not a fellow listen
in a world where everybody has a chip on
their shoulder i just make it a point to
not
how about that and you want to make it a
point to just believe the best yeah
assume
good intentions and go with that yeah so
we turned out better by the way
there's a little nugget for you guys
they do it's gonna be okay
and uh we have a tremendous amount of
fun when we get to be together
uh we have a lot of uh of in sync
thoughts and and and heart towards
people
plus we can answer the money questions
and we can talk about your business
starting a side hustle christy with
business boutique doing some crazy stuff
hey
you feel like life is spinning out of
control and you're just like time is a
real problem
she can help you there it can help you
with your work moving up
figuring out what you want to do with
your life what were you born to do how
do i make more
money and then of course the money
question so it's wide open we have a
blast
working together to help you it is a
free phone call i don't know why you
wouldn't do it
triple eight eight two five five two two
five christy said
if you've wanted to call in but you're
scared of dave you don't have to be
scared of that she said that not me
we're not scared dave is listening do
you think i watch this i don't know he
might i don't think he does
i don't think he does he's got a lot
going on no triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number let's oh
you got something well i was just gonna
remind people when you're thinking about
calling in
one of the things that you and i are
great at in particular is helping you
get your income
up yes so whether that's because you
want to pay for
shovels you want to have a bigger shovel
you want to pay off your debt faster you
just want to make more money period
whatever that is ken and i in our
different ways
are great at helping you come up with
strategies to make more money whether
that's a promotion through your job
through a business or some combination
so if you
are thinking about how you can get your
income up how you can make more money to
make more progress on your financial
goals faster
we're the people to call so give us call
triple eight five five two two five
all right let's do it justin joins us in
houston texas justin how can we help
howdy everyone um i am in
baby step four five and six and uh
first of all that is a blessing to be in
that that spot so what i'm about to say
i don't want to
make it sound like i'm complaining but
we have we've optimized
everything in our lives in terms of you
know financially we're exactly where
we should be at this point in time but i
gotta be honest i'm a little bit
kind of unmotivated because like
paying off our house is still nine or
ten years away
and kids college is still a number of
years away
so there's no like real immediate wins
that i see in our future
other than just every month you know the
first of every month it's like
cha-ching you know a little bit more
equity in the house a little bit more
money in the bank a little bit more
money in retirement and a little bit
more money to our church but
besides that there's really nothing to
get the juices going
so do you have any thoughts on this yes
are we talking just money context
because if we are it might change my
answer are you
are you looking for a game to win with
your money is that specifically why
you're calling
i mean i got a beautiful family and a
great job
and and there's a lot of great things
going on but so yeah i guess
i would say more financially because
it's what fault
it sounds like you're bored with it well
it sounds like you're a goal-oriented
person that doesn't have a goal
that's exactly right well yeah because i
mean i've spent the past six months like
getting life insurance squared away
getting
you know like fine-tuning everything
with our wheels
there's nothing left to do now you're a
doer and you don't know what to do right
yeah i gotta go all right
well i'll just say this i i think you've
got a narrative problem
i i i don't think you're bored uh i
think you feel bored i think that's real
that you feel bored but i think you've
got a narrative problem where you're
like you're just running this thing out
and christy's right you got it on the
rails
this thing is on the rails but i think
you're forgetting that each month that
this thing just stays on the rails that
you're just doing
all of the stuff you're supposed to do
you are making massive
massive progress don't forget that
you've got to kind of get in this
routine
to end up where you want to get to where
the end of the road and the house is
paid off and then
baby step 7 you're living like no one
else the only other thing i'd say i'll
turn over to christy on this one but
the only thing i'd say is that's the
first issue that i see
the second thing is i think you could
carve out something to do with your
money and make some progress in another
area maybe
in a form of giving uh or investing
into something or somebody uh outside of
our traditional 15 towards retirement
that's what i'm saying i i think you
could find
uh uh some type of incentive
to do some with your money i would
challenge you on that issue as well
justin i just want to say one thing
um no it's not just one that's totally
false advertising i have several things
to say
justin first uh how you're feeling is
normal
a lot of people in four five and six
feel this way because you've been so
gazelle intense and it's such a specific
milestone when you've accomplished baby
step one a thousand dollars baby step
two
debt free baby step three emergency fund
funded it's so specific
that when you get into this it's more of
a marathon not a sprint and it's just
this
kind of great area it's not like you're
still investing you'll be doing this
simultaneously for a while
that's super normal so let me just
encourage you that it's normal second
thing i would say
is um you can choose to get intense
about any of those things anytime you
want to i i have been hosting the
the show with um dave and the last few
times i've hosted with him
almost every single debt-free scream is
someone that's paid off their house
because they just chose
to get intense about their house you can
always do that if you want to don't have
to but that's an option if that would
motivate you and then third um and this
is something just like ken said
if you're a goal-oriented person and you
don't have a goal just make a goal
just decide just make something up
justin i'm gonna make up something just
say
what if this christmas we went to
walmart and paid off the
layaways of ten thousand dollars worth
of people and you save up between now
and december and you
like that that's exciting i made that up
but you can do that let me give you a
running example when i get bored with my
running because i love to run
i just make up new goals i have run the
country music marathon
normal i've tried to pr it i've run it
pregnant
uh i've run it 12 weeks after having
carter
pregnant with conley um okay we know
you're awesome could you please stop for
those of us who don't run a lot sheesh
i'm feeling more guilty
with each time she ticks off another
thing it's not impressive
i did it with a bag of rocks one time i
did it with a person on my shoulders
what else is left i should run it with
you on my back that would be
ken is so pissed are we close to a
commercial break it's not that i'm
impressive the point is that i set new
challenges i know
i set new challenges yeah i know justin
if you're good with your money set a new
challenge for yourself that excites you
find something that excites you i'm
actually not that great
okay i just challenged myself people it
was slow
yeah it was a slow run and that was
okay so uh we got to do this thing
called a commercial break
i'm gonna go set some goals and set some
physical challenges and do some push-ups
in the studio just to be able to sit
at the desk with the force of nature
that is known as christie wright hey
don't move the ramsey show
[Music]
oh
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you
make the most out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm kid
coleman ramsey personality and host of
the ken coleman show on the ramsey
network i'm joined by my colleague
christy wright she's the host of the
christy wright show and is also a ramsey
personality
thrilled to have you with us and we are
taking your calls today
on your life your money your work and
beyond how many of you are working your
dream job
turns out most people aren't but work
doesn't have to be a four-letter word
you were meant for more than mediocre
work
my new book is entitled from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing work you
love it's now available
for pre-orders it doesn't matter who you
are where you are what industry what
type of work
if you've got a place you want to be in
the marketplace work
money all of it and meaning we've got a
step-by-step plan you can get the get
hired bonus pack and the get promoted
bonus pack
free when you pre-order the book
that's over 100 of value you can go to
ramseysolutions.com and you can
pre-order
from paycheck to purpose today for only
twenty dollars and get the hundred
dollars worth of free bonus items also
give me that book let me see this one i
want to talk about this i want to see i
want to show your book for youtube
people that are on youtube because it's
so beautiful and
tell people i've never been called
beautiful in my life considering
i said the book was like oh i'm sorry
the design you just happen to be a part
of it
yeah selective listening yeah hey
explain for people that have never
pre-ordered a book before
because you and i do this all the time
so we know explain why you should
pre-order
explain why we do pre-order and what
they get for pre-ordering because we
know
that it's not going to get mailed to you
until your launch date of november 9th
november 9th
yeah but if you pre-order we we are
going to bribe you with all this stuff
slash reward say thank you with all this
stuff because it helps
us with our marketing yes and we drive
we're trying to drive to best seller
list so that more people
outside of ramsey solutions right you
those of you that listen to the show
will buy the book and so we drive that
so there's the strategic reason but we
also bribe you
um with the hundred dollars of free
stuff and uh depending on if you want to
get hired or get promoted that's why we
have those two different
uh bonus offerings but i also have to
mention
the deal that's popping right now at
ramseysolutions.com is the assessment
the get
clear career assessment which will
measure your talent passion and mission
fill out your purpose statement
and show you professional possibilities
you get that for 30 bucks
and basically the book's for free you
get the assessment
and the book all for 30 bucks so that's
kind of stupid and this is such a good
assessment because it shows you it was
just like overtime it shows you what you
need to do
i love the cover when we when you y'all
were testing very nervous my pick
you did like christie do i look just
like it leaned it like
so you're seriously you look so
approachable thank you it's so relatable
and it was amazing give me anxiety as
you know hey it's like what we just said
the clear path to doing work you love
the clear
here hand me yours for a second we just
talked about my book
so now i gotta look because if you if i
you said all these nice things
but look at this guy i mean this guy or
this gal i'm never
gonna be able to look like that feed off
her hands beat off
feet off shoes she does have feet that
alarmed a lot of people right there
that was that was scary am the most
talented footless runner
in the united states oh here we go again
with the running
by the way then i tried to run a
marathon with actually no feet
that's true oh my gosh i meant shoes i
meant she's
wait listen it's friday this is what you
get if you put me on stage
so there you go and by the way you can
get her book as well so i don't know why
you wouldn't buy both right now
ramsay solutions.com we're having fun
i gotta mention this because there's
cash involved before we move on
uh because it's the pre-order of the
book here the launch of uh from paycheck
to purpose
they're giving away 500 cash every week
this month christy and then i guess at
the end of the month
they're giving away three thousand
dollars so uh if you text the word
cash to three three seven eight nine
like you could not even i'm just helping
people you could care less about my book
but if you text the word cash to three
three seven eight nine you might win
some money so i
would at least do that yes yes just
trying to help people out
get cash get cash triple eight eight two
five five
two two five is the phone number triple
eight eight two five
five two two five aaron joins us in
portland oregon
erin how can we help hey how are you
guys doing thanks for taking my call you
bet sir
what's going on hey so quick
i'm just in a you need a question
for you guys my wife and i are both uh
we're
um debt-free congratulations including
the house
wow way to go
thank you and we have a pretty good
amount in our um iras
and none um non-ira accounts
so i am thinking of our the company i
work for
merged with a bigger company last
february so 2020 right before covet hit
um we went from 80 employees to about
900 and since that time
you know the infrastructure has been
pretty no communication and all of that
so
it's just been a struggle so for a whole
year i've been thinking of
making a change and went through the um
the master's program for coaching got
that all done and i think we're at that
point where i was going to call you and
just say
hey is this a good time since we're debt
free
have emergency fund have a good
retirement is it time for me to
spread my wings and look elsewhere well
maybe let's go to the coaching thing why
did you get your why'd you do the
financial coach master training here at
ramsey solutions
tell us um my wife and i went through
uh financial university and that's how
we became debt free
sure after that at work monthly
i actually put in a little financial
spot in our newsletter for our company
we talk about the baby steps we talk
about that free
we talk about budgeting and um
patients that i deal with and work with
are a lot
older so you can see the struggle that
they're having with
cataract surgeries or some things like
that so
i tend to sit with them and we visit
about
sure about budget and all of that so you
know it's just something that i've
always wanted to do for the last three
years when he took my wife and i to pay
off the house
and so aaron
you should do it you should do it but
this does not require you to leave your
current job
okay but you should start coaching you
should start saying all right i'm going
to charge for my coaching
our fcmt program is fantastic you've
been to the training but they also help
you grow your business
and you know that you're going to have
to get out there and one foot in front
of the other we got to get one client we
got to coach them up
we got to keep coaching them and then we
got to move on to the next this is an
entrepreneurial journey
christy could speak to this but i think
the answer is absolutely yes you started
i don't think you leave it
quick question how much money do you
make right now what's your salary
um well we have household income about
about a hundred thousand so
okay um so if i told you it goes between
if i told you that you could make a
hundred thousand dollars
okay being a financial coach would you
hesitate or would you jump
i jump all right there's your answer all
right christy tell him how he does this
how does he build this from scratch
yeah you just ignore the side exactly
like you said it's not gonna be a jump
we're gonna build it up towards the step
and that's what we tell people when
you're starting a side gig
you keep the full-time job you keep the
steady salary
and you start this on the side and you
build it up so much so you're getting
more clients and more hours and more
revenue more income
up up up up until you can live on that
amount of money now it doesn't have to
be 100 grand when you
take the step or jump as you want to say
it maybe you build it up to
50 or 60 and it's just continuing to
climb then you can quit the full-time
job and work on it full-time
working towards a hundred grand on that
side business but i just want to
encourage you
we have a ton of resources here erin
through our financial
coach team they do coaching calls we do
events in in the fall i'll be speaking
at their event called
enrichment in september i'll be there
and we'll yeah ken and i will both be
there so we love to help coaches
build their businesses into profitable
businesses because it's not just the
coaching it's not just what you're doing
it's the business aspect you need to
know as well and i just want you to know
erin those resources are available to
you from a support standpoint
and ongoing standpoint so just know if
you want to do it we'll help you do that
and aaron you have worked so hard you're
doing awesome you have the financial
freedom to do this
yes we're still not gonna jump we're
gonna just build this thing
i would re-engage as christy said with
our financial coach
resources build this thing one person at
a time
before you know it you're going to be
doing it full-time i love your heart you
love coaching people
pursue it don't feel the pressure to do
it all
super fast and super big you've got this
thank you so much
for the call my colleague is chrissy
wright i'm ken coleman with ramsey
personality you are listening to
the ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back america you have joined the
conversation here on
the ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined
by my colleague christy wright
we are thrilled to be together to help
you to serve you
here's how we do it it's a free phone
call triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five
two two five we'll talk about your money
we'll talk about
your side hustle the business we'll talk
about your time we'll talk about your
work and
career and moving up getting that bigger
shovel making more money
we'll even talk leadership you know
christie it occurs to me that the other
day you know it's like
people want to get promoted it's one of
the f it's one of the stages my seven
stages get promoted
but if you're gonna get promoted it's
almost guaranteed you're gonna be in
some type of leadership role
you know it's very rare that you would
get promoted and not lead yeah so
christy and i are very involved with
entre leadership
and we can answer your leadership
questions um
here's a fun one some of you are in a
very toxic work situation
and i get those questions all the time
on the ken coleman show but i want to
take on one of those with you
because of the leadership component do
you know what i mean like okay what do i
do here or
how about i'm running a small business
and i got a high performer
who's a cancer but it's a little i mean
i'd love for you to take those kind of
questions on too
it was it's all over the place it's so
interesting too because a lot of the
questions we get
they come in as like oh this is a
leadership question or this is a
business question or this is even a
money question
and we dig into it and it's actually a
people question it almost
always down to a relationship issue
and ken and i love helping unpack that
with you so give us a call triple
h five five two two five all right let's
go to pensacola florida where jody joins
us jody how can we help
thank you kindly for hearing me out sure
what's going on
thank you i'm a retired military officer
thank you for your service thank you you
are a great american
i discovered mr ramsey after i became
debt free
wow all right and i
also own my own home awesome
and uh yes thank you i'm flying solo now
operating a small hobby farm
and i'm looking for a less painful
side hustle than what what i do now yeah
you mean like physically taxing
uh mentally and physically yeah that's
just
what i'm doing now as a side hustle it's
it's a lot of work
and it's just becoming less enjoyable
okay how much money is it spitting off
for you
how much money yeah how much you making
off of it i started doing a side hustle
september 2nd and uh i have
total now this is gross i've made
uh 10 900 from doing it
and this is this past september yes
ma'am okay all right well let's just
start with your ideas
let's just kind of walk through this
what ideas do you have for something
that you would like to do on the side
have you been working on that and
thinking about it
oh yes yes i think about it every day i
right what i've been doing since
september since i have a small hobby
farm
i joined a couple agri-tourism
venues where dry campers rvs fifth
wheels tent campers
uh boondock stay overnight on my land
in exchange for either paying up front
or with the other the second venue they
stay overnight here
free with the suggestion that they
buy a product from me in exchange for
the free stay
and from that i average about 40
per reservation but i'm enjoying doing
that less unless
it just seems to be becoming more toxic
i used to enjoy it interaction with
people
the old school uh rvers
uh who are genuine cordial and very
interesting but
increasingly um there's just become more
drama more problems jody here's what i
want you to do i want you to tell
christy those things that you're really
excited about you
when she asked you that you were like oh
yes there was a little bit of a spark
what are these ideas that you've had
it's not these toxic rvers
what's the idea that sounds good let's
start with that one
yes doing what i do now without
the element of them staying on property
overnight i love teaching
i've been making kombucha beverage
every week for 16 years and i i i've
been selling that
to my guests and i also teach
workshops but there's an increasing
number of folks who are interested in
micro brewing or becoming a micro
brewery
or a brewmeister making their own
kombucha health beverage i'm sure you're
familiar with that sure
so yes doing the workshops and my
my claim to fame there is that i've
kept my cultures alive for 16 years
which i understand is very rare
so i love teaching i come from a long
history of teachers
i love sharing knowledge i love helping
people i love
mentoring new newly formed meisters
i'm also a writer i i have four books
that i've self-published
i'm working on a fifth one um i love
mentoring people
i love fixing things um my my ideal job
or not job but side hustle would be
buying old toyotas and fixing them and
okay so hold on a second so so that was
a really long list to get to my
ideal side hustle which is why i think
you called so
how much capital do you need to start
buying toyotas and fixing one up give me
a quick example
i i have savings um i capital's not a
problem no no i'm saying
uh give me an example a camry uh tacoma
what would you buy and fix it up and
flip it give us a quick run through that
how that would work
i'll buy it i'd buy an older toyota uh
preferably manual transmission
which is not that many of them but um
older
uh older corolla older uh pickup truck
sr5 and you put how much in it two or
three grand five grand then flip it for
what eight or nine
well no not not not even five grand
sometimes people
will ditch their older cars because they
need a new alternator and they don't
have their own
money you know i guess i don't
understand why you wouldn't do this
you've got this all figured out i i do i
know why she wouldn't do it listen jodi
i have
i have one challenge to the toyota idea
i'm not against the toyota idea but the
very reason you told me you want to get
out of farming is because it's so
physical
we're going to go from physical farming
to car flipping
that's part of it i i'm going to keep
the hobby farm i mean it's it's a lot of
work but i grow my own food i mean
that's the whole
point of my uh what's the part that's
physically taxing you that you don't
want to keep doing at the hobbies
this is a very simple answer about that
piece of it you've got a lot going on
you got a lot of ideas and i think
that's awesome
we need to get rid of the campers that's
that's something you can do
as soon as your latest reservation is
we're not offering this anymore we need
to be done with that it's stressing you
out you know it i know it we can all
hear it all of america
can hear it in your voice as for the
other ideas what i find interesting
is that you spent a lot of time saying
teaching writing teaching writing
workshops microbrewing
you spent a lot of time on that and then
you came to my ideal job as toyotas
i'm not saying it's not i'm just saying
what i heard you say over and over again
was the teaching writing
i think you need some clarity on what
this next business idea
is and then when you know what that is
then you'll know what action to take but
you're trying to do all the things
i heard teaching and writing i heard
teaching people how to micro brew you're
making your drinks and all your stuff on
the side
selling that as a product line and also
having an online
stream now if you want to do the toyota
thing that's cool hold on
you're absolutely right christy but i
but i want to ask you jody christy's
right
there was a lot there and then you just
went but my ideal job
is fixing toilets so which one is it
let's do the old fun quiz
there's no answer there's no wrong
answer but if you had to choose today
guaranteed success
which one would you choose if you could
only choose one
i would actually do both i know you
would
i'm saying right now which one do you
think you get most
enjoyment out of learning learning how
to make videos and post them on youtube
okay all right here's what i want to do
jody i want you to stay on the line
i'm going to have kelly send you two
things first
i wanted to send you my course business
idea boot camp this is a course i
created years ago to help you come up
with your best business idea i want you
to
list
all your ideas and you got a lot put
them all on there and you're gonna run
them through several tests that i have
to find your best business idea
and then i want you to come to my
conference business boutique in october
you can come in nashville in person or
you can watch on live stream
you come to that conference with your
idea that you found from this course
and then we're gonna show you how to act
on it and build it but you need to
figure out which idea you're going to
act on or else you're going to keep
running a million directions and making
progress and none of them
so those two things it's a one-two punch
business idea boot camp and then the
conference will give you what you need
to do and one other thing jody please
bring a case of kombucha please
please please do that i would like to
have some
the homemade kombucha i'm in she had me
there i
love it hey she's christy wright i'm ken
coleman this
is the ramsay show don't move
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague christy wright
we're taking you through this hour as we
answer your questions about life
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
triple eight eight two five five
two two five does it feel like no matter
what you do how hard you work you just
can't get ahead with your money
well we've been there before but you
don't have to live like that if you're
sick and tired of being sick and tired
decide
now that you're ready to do something
different and if you do you'll get
different results it's time to commit to
a plan that works financial peace
university
is the step-by-step plan that's helped
nearly six million people pay off debt
and take control of their money
you combine that with the premium
version of the every dollar budgeting
tool and you will make progress
instantly and it's only available with a
membership
to ramsey plus decide today to break the
cycle of living paycheck to paycheck
this month only we're all we're taking
thirty dollars
off the price of a 12-month membership
start your free trial of ramsay plus
today by texting trial
to 33789 that's trial
text that word to 33789
all right kansas city kansas is where we
go next and brett joins us there brett
how can we help
hello hi brett hi
you're on the ramsay show it's all you
buddy
what's your question um sorry
i'm just having trouble hearing that's
all right i i've got an idea for a
product
okay um that i think would be pretty
cheap to manufacture
and retail i mean a pretty good price
point um i've never done that before
should i try to bankroll the whole thing
myself should i take out loans i know
you guys are
pretty against uh financing
yeah so we'll go ahead and answer that
part of the question we don't want you
um
just any other again having never walked
this path before if there's any caveats
you can throw out there you know
don't take any wooden nickels sure so
let's start with you
listen okay hold on a second i'm so
confused right now
uh first brett you should not take out a
loan we do not want you to take out a
loan
anytime you're getting into any kind of
business
there's so much involved and a loan is
bad idea regardless
of how great the idea is and it's
certainly a horrible idea when we're not
even sure if this thing's gonna work so
no
loan and also we would not take on
investors or partnerships we're not a
fan of that
um that eats into your ownership uh
christy what else would you walking
through here on this brent i'm curious
uh can you share the idea or is it a
secret
i think well it's um it's such a simple
idea it would be really you could steal
it so yeah
that's cool okay so i'm just gonna i'm
gonna give you some general advice
it's a computer accessory okay all right
here's here's a life hack
computer accessory got it got it okay
cool so stop brett you're going to give
the idea away
i'm going to give you i'm going to give
you some very simple i have not i've
been
i've been googling for something like it
and the only things
that are close on the market don't
wouldn't even touch it so great all
right
great it would outpace anything in its
class great
that's on the market right now and it
would be it would be probably
19.95 at this point perfect i i believe
that and we're going to prove it through
starting small growing slow so here's
what i want you to do you've already
done some research to see what's out
there and there's not much here's what i
want you to do i want you to look for
manufacturing options for a prototype
you can pay a very very small fee
to get different manufacturers
to create a prototype for you where you
can have a
mock-up you can say yeah a little bit
more this a little less of this and you
can actually source it from multiple
vendors to see who's going to give you
the best price point who
how they do their pricing and also just
what's the quality what's the
functionality because i don't know the
exact product i can't
advise you to a specific direction but
you know what i'm talking about you're
gonna whatever this thing is if it's
plastic if it's material it's whatever
you're gonna source different
manufacturers i would say get at least
three
get them to create three different
prototypes you're working with each of
them and comparing
the um the minimum orders the turnaround
time
if do you like them are they good with
customer service and responsiveness to
you because you're you're
depending on them um and and what's the
quality does it have the functionality
that you want and so on
and then from there while you're doing
this because this will take a little
time for them to create
while you're doing this i want you to
start working on
um validating the concept now you can do
that through surveys you can do it
through asking friends and family you
can do it through social media
uh ask about the pain points that this
thing
solves so let me give you an example
okay my book it's not a it's not a
product is what you're talking about
with like something with your computer
but before we created this book or
before ken created his book
we did research hey do you struggle with
managing your time do you feel like you
don't have enough time
what's your biggest frustration with
your career move what we do
research to understand the felt need of
the people that we're going to help with
this thing that we're going to create
i want you to do that brett i want you
to understand
the people that need this product what
are their pain points
how do they talk about it guess what
that's going to become your marketing
language
the things they say are the things
you're going to say when you market this
and then when you do that you can even
begin to create an
email list you can create some social
media pages start to
generate interest in this area and then
when you have it you have a group of
people to market it too
from there you can look at selling it
into retail stores
if you want to go that route in addition
to selling it independently yourself but
really just the first step for you
is you're going to take your money and
go get a prototype
made and so you've got two main avenues
two tracks you're walking at the same
time you're getting the prototype made
and
val getting all that figured out and
fine-tuned while
you're doing market research and testing
and understanding your market if you do
that
you can start to put it out there and
then guess what you're selling this
thing
now if it does not skyrocket overnight
like you hope and dream that it will
don't be discouraged because you're
starting this thing from scratch it
doesn't mean it's not a good idea
that's where you put fuel on the fire of
marketing and you've got to broadcast it
and get it out there to the right people
in the right hands
and if it is as good as you say it is
then it will sell itself when it gets in
the right hands and the right people
know about it so there's some tactical
things for you to do
guess what every person that's ever
created a new product does that exact
thing
it's not some special secret that they
have that you don't they didn't know
what they were doing either and they did
it anyway so you can do that too it's
great advice that you just got brett
don't forget what she said earlier
you're starting
small and growing slow everything she
gave you tactically has to come back to
that
you're first do you feel like you're not
starting small or going slow
then you need to slow down and just back
off your first order should be less than
a thousand yeah if you're starting with
no email list now if you're starting
with some major platform
you did not mention to me maybe it's a
bigger first order but if this is top
secret and you don't have a platform
your first order is less than a thousand
period for sure
and that can reorder as needed that's
after you've done all that testing that
chrissy told you you know one of the
things i find christy that
it's so exciting you know for
entrepreneurs certainly inventors or
something like this they come up with an
idea
and they're like everybody's got to have
it it's going to be an absolute big
success i mean we've both been down that
road before personally we certainly
understand that
but what happens is if you aren't
willing to let this thing get
ripped apart by people like certainly a
gadget
let's call it that you've got to test
that and put that in front of people and
be willing for people to go
i'd never buy this in a million years
this sucks
not to be discouraged but to make sure
that you don't order something and you
don't go down the road
with something that in your mind's eye
was this wonderful idea and you never
truly get real feedback and it's got to
be
people beyond uncle larry so i'm you
make such a good point because i think
so many people
it's this fine line of you don't want
one critic to derail your whole plans if
it's just one
but if everyone's saying this then like
you should pay attention to it listen
have you ever had a product before
where you used it you're like what idiot
created this oh like for sure how did
they miss this like did they not
test it they did they not think when
they created this
and and it's just so funny because it's
like we've all been there and you want
to avoid your customers thinking that
and you just
listen to them ask for their feedback
good bad ugly everything in between
they're gonna tell you what they like
and don't like and then you can go fix
it
in order to make it closer to what they
need and i'm glad you brought this up
you're right chrissy that doesn't mean
they're haters or doubters these are
people just testing your product there's
a difference
yeah if one person your friend goes
that's a dumb idea
and you just stop everything because of
that well that's the opposite of what
you just gave
right the advice for brett to do but
we're saying you really test the product
consumer testing user testing
because that you may have twenty percent
hate it fifty percent
really like it and fifteen are
indifferent whatever and you don't hear
anything
whatever it is but you gotta be able to
lean into that because when you do
it's invaluable information so that you
don't get too far down the road well let
me give you an example i will not buy a
handbag
that i cannot put on with one arm
because the straps are long enough if i
have to take this arm to slide it on
because the slap
the straps are too short i won't buy it
someone that
has kids and is busy they know that
they've they've made it
yeah just think through like the
functionality of what you're using and
who's going to use it it's going to help
you
good stuff thanks for the call brett
great advice chrissy want to thank my
colleague christy wright so much fun
this
hour i want to thank our producer ben
hill our associate producer kelly daniel
and you america you're listening to the
ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermsyshow.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
life money relationships
businesses your career journey your time
just about everything that matters
anything you want to talk about that's
right we're here for it
she is christy wright i'm ken coleman
we're here together for you
it is a free number to call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five
and uh chris and i are having more fun
than you should be allowed to have
when you host a radio show but why
wouldn't you the advice is free so if
you don't like it
we'll give you a refund what's the big
deal why wouldn't you
call and if you don't like us you can
just send us hate mail but we have great
assistance we'll never see it
i'm so glad you said because i i don't
ever read those i
remember when i first started four years
ago the ken coleman show and i told my
producer i said listen
no matter how awful it is or how
entertaining it is to you
sir don't ever show me nope
and and what is it about the bravery
christy uh of people behind a keyboard
they would
never dare look you in the eye and say
the things they say to you
or me when they fire an email or a my
favorite is the uh
passive aggressive holier-than-thou
arrogant
i just got you comment on social media
yes
that's my favorite my personal favorite
i'm just gonna leave this here
and walk away yeah uh you know what i
was thinking the other day um you know
how a lot of people say everyone should
have to be a server so you empathize
with servers and restaurants
i would totally agree i've been a server
too i'm so much nicer to serve respect
i get that i think everyone should have
to be on camera
and just allow everyone to screw it up
let everyone have a youtube show where
everyone's just
i don't like your hair i don't like it i
don't like how she said that that's
right
i think it's true let them feel yeah
that comment
people might be a little nicer oh you
might be gonna be a little nicer if they
get to experience what it's
like to be in the public eye yeah yeah
why don't you share
something that comes from your heart
that you want to help somebody why don't
you just put that out there
and let somebody rip it
yeah we won't see that's the price of
admission though and we are okay with it
triple eight eight two
five five by the way what they don't
know is what we say about them
there are breaks here for a reason
people jk jk we love y'all
next question so what does that mean oh
just kidding i can't
you have to help me with this i'm about
a 47 year old dad that's not a new thing
jk i wasn't in middle school all right
fantastic there it is she's helping me
she keeps me
current triple eight eight two five five
two two five
is the phone number to jump in let's go
to big springs texas that seems like a
really great place to be from
big springs texas is where robert joins
us robert how can we help
yeah i'm just trying to figure out how
to get that for you being on the list
i'm talking about doing it
for a while now and we're trying as a
keyword
i'm trying to work all right well let's
let's just start how did you get
connected to us how'd you hear about us
um i'm at work listening to the radio
all right cool
awesome i i listen to it a lot
because i can't get it when i'm home so
i live when i'm out this way
a lot okay cool awesome well
robert i'll tell you we were actually
talking about this earlier but
everything we teach about money
career time management anything we break
down into really simple steps because we
believe that if you have a clear path
and steps
then it's a lot easier to do it and so
dave's money principles dave ramsey's
money principles that this
organization ramsey solutions is founded
on uh are
seven baby steps seven very specific
steps that you take
in your money in order to get control of
your money and have financial freedom
and be able to
to build wealth and give and do whatever
you want to so um
the first step in the baby steps is to
get a thousand dollars really super fast
so this can't be something i'm gonna
save ten dollars for a real long time
really super fast get a thousand dollars
sell so much stuff the kids think
they're next
get that thousand dollars and you're
gonna put that in a savings account
just for any type of emergency that
might come up when you start using
stop using debt which is now so if you
stop using debt you stop using credit
cards which is what we want you to do
you're gonna need that
it's called a starter emergency fund and
you put a thousand dollars in your
savings account so if your
br you know tire blows out you can cover
it not have to use your credit card that
you've been used to using for example
and so you get that thousand dollar
starter emergency fund and then you
begin to pay off
all your debts smallest to largest
by balance so what i want you to do
robert is i want you to make a list of
all your debts any type of debt
credit card car loan student loan
personal line of credit medical bills
whatever
all your debts you're gonna list them
out in order
by smallest to largest balanced i want
you to
ignore the interest rate i know this
sounds counter-intuitive
people all the time say oh shouldn't i
pay off the highest interest rate first
because then i would be
listen if we were doing math we would
have never got ourselves in this
situation people so we're going to focus
on smallest largest because we
found that quick wins are motivating for
you to stay with the plan
so you want to get that quick win you
pay off that smallest debt you mark it
out on your list cut up that credit card
or close that account whatever it is and
then you roll that into the next one so
what you're going to do is you're going
to
attack that smallest debt when you're in
baby step 2
and you're going to pay minimums on
everything else and then when that
smallest debt is paid off you mark it
off cut it up close the account whatever
roll that payment into the next smallest
debt you attack that debt
pay minimums on everything else and this
is what we call the debt snowball you
keep doing that until you get to your
largest
debt which is most likely your student
loan if you have a student loan a car
loan something like that
we don't include the mortgage in this
step this is just consumer debt so all
debt you have other than the house and
that's called baby step number two
and then when you're debt free which is
super exciting and a really big deal
you never go back into debt again you
want to begin to save up cash
for your fully funded emergency fund
which is three to six months of
expenses and this is going to be the
cushion and protection between you
and an emergency in life like a
something like a job loss or health
scare some medical bill you have to take
care of you can be able to pay cash when
you have that savings and so
those are the first three steps first
step step number one thousand dollar
emergency fund step number two pay off
all debts
smallest to largest buy balance
baby step number three three to six
months of expenses and then once you get
that
you're ready for baby steps four five
six and
seven four is to be investing fifteen
percent we don't recommend to invest
until you're baby step number four in
debt free baby step number five is to
fund kids college fund if you have kids
you want to fund their college and then
baby step
six pay off the home early baby step
seven build wealth
and give and the whole idea robert is
that you've got to have an
incredible intensity and momentum
and gusto gazelle intensity is what we
call it
especially in those first three steps
because when you said to me when you
asked this question robert you said
we've been trying to get out of debt
we've been trying
trying is different than being committed
to it so you've got to commit
you've got to take debt off the table it
is no longer an option we're going to
cut up those cards which i know is scary
we're going to close those accounts when
they're debt-free which i know feels
vulnerable but you're gonna have that
emergency fund to protect you we're now
operating on a cash system
not a debt system so you've got to
change your mindset
and change your behavior and commit to
this plan
the only way that it works is if you
commit to it
we're gonna stop trying and we're gonna
commit and we're gonna do it stay on the
line i'll have kelly send us
send you the total money makeover which
is dave's best-selling book that shows
you how to do this
step-by-step in detail great stuff it's
as clear
as it can be and it works over and over
and over again robert you got this
appreciate the call debt free is in
your future don't move more of your
calls coming right up this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk simply smarter wireless
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
christy wright we're taking your calls
this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color they'll remake
your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
if you use the promo code ramsay to get
the best deal today's question comes
from
b in california my business closed
due to covet and i'm struggling to find
another job i owned a day spa
with 22 independent contractors for 10
years
but now the only job i can get is
waitressing
not true but i understand i've applied
for jobs in different fields but i keep
getting turned down
i even applied for a job in collections
and offered to go to school to learn
about that industry but the manager was
looking for someone with experience i'm
confused lost
and heartbroken i don't have to work
since we are debt free and my husband
makes a great living but i want to find
my new
niche uh needs your niche do you call
that niche i call it niche i feel like
the safer i feel like if you say niche
you're trying to be fancy and i think my
brain just
messed with me right there in the middle
of it i did an articulation of
nichinish it was like nish i said nish
i don't know what's going on ah there
you go any advice you could give would
be much appreciated okay so much here
um let's start with the fact that i want
you to take the pressure off of yourself
b
because you don't have to make a living
because of your fight your financial
situation being debt free and your
husband have a good job
let's take a deep breath here it feels
like you're really pressing because i
hear i
wanted to think about going into
collections and even going to
school to learn about that industry and
it's just like i'm just grasping i'm
searching right now
and the reality is that you need to step
back and go
what do i just want to do that has even
nothing to do with a paycheck let me
just go do something that i'd like to do
and begin that process of discovery i
would love for you
to go to kencolma.com or
ramseysolutions.com and you can get the
get clear career assessment begin to
look at
talent passion and mission talent's what
you do best think of talent as tools
there's clues christine when you figure
out
what you do well and then we look at
what would i love to do
but i think in this situation uh i focus
more on passion with b
and what i help callers with christie on
pat on mission
is when they're trying to figure out the
specificity of the work
many times it helps to just ask the
three-part question who are the people i
most want to help
what problem do they have or desire do
they have that i want to solve
and what's the solution to that if you
break that down could be a problem
it could be i want to make women feel
beautiful right so i'm going to go into
maybe the beauty industry or something
like that i want to design shoes clothes
whatever it doesn't always have to be a
problem but it is always a problem or a
desire
that you associate with certain people
and then what are the solutions to that
so i think b that's where i'd start but
i think you've got to relax here
because just trying things from
collections
to waitressing i mean it's just all over
the board
and i think that there's some sort of
christy uh self-imposed pressure and we
can't answer this in detail because it's
over an email but what do you hear in
that i'm curious that this question from
b
actually makes me want to ask a bigger
question of just
in general and your thoughts on this can
i wonder
how many businesses closed due to covet
because they could not cash flow in the
the closures
but they stayed closed only because of
discouragement
because that's a great question if you
had a business
for 10 years b and you had 22
independent contractors
and you knew how to do this and you did
it well why could you not do it again
why could you not restart it now would
you get
all of your clients back that you were
at your peak probably not they found
other solutions but i bet you'd get some
back let me use an example ken
uh some of my favorite businesses from a
lunch place in brentwood
to a yoga studio downtown don't at me
with all your feelings about yoga it's a
form of exercise people listen
we'll have clothes i feel like there
might be something there we got to dig
into in a moment oh no take care of b
i'm going to circle back yoga studio and
sandwich shop both closed due to kovid
and they're not back but if they open
back up i would be there in a heart
along with several other people like you
that's right because
because it the concept was proven and
uh she did it before she knows how to do
it the scary part of starting she
doesn't have to do that
it's just when someone gets knocked out
like in boxing someone gets knocked down
and out
man it's like getting up is hard but
there may be a percentage of businesses
in
the united states that did not restart
because of finances or because the
market genuinely shifted
i get that that that is true for some
it's not true for all of them i wonder
how many did not open back up
simply because they were discouraged and
i wonder if bee's one of those people
because
she doesn't even mention that
interestingly it's not even an option
and why
i just think it's too much pain because
she could go work for a spa
having owned a spa business she doesn't
even mention that as just a job
she doesn't even need the money i wonder
if i think you've really
i mean it's hard to read into something
like this but i think you're on to
something there's a lot of pain
associated with him to shut that
business down to where she goes
i might go get trained to be in
collections have you ever heard anybody
say that in your life
no and it's the furthest thing from spa
100 and the other thing that's so
interesting about business and this is
what i
talk about this a lot through all the
work i do through business boutique
business is personal it's you it's your
heart it's your skills it's your
services your knowledge this is your
baby
and so someone rejects the business it
feels like they're rejecting you it does
feel personal
absolutely and what's interesting is
even if you had a very successful
business
if you had to close those doors because
of
all the regulations closures quarantine
all the stuff that happened last year
yeah i wonder how many of those business
owners even though they knew in their
head
i am facing an impossible situation in
their heart if it felt like i failed
i i failed and they didn't want to go
back into that
i think you're all over there i don't
think
the people that are starting again
people are absolutely
packing those restaurants out there
packing those those exercise studios
whatever the thing is
out and yeah you may have to build it up
a little bit again and you may have to
find a new space because that space is
gone
but i just want bee to start it again
take care of people
yeah i think there's a lot of a lot of
pain associated with this and she's just
going i need a fresh start or it is
possible we just don't know this
that she's looking for something else
but i i this self-imposed pressure
i mean she's actually in a really really
good position financially where she
doesn't have this pressure i've got to
go get
ajob right so you know it's very
interesting stuff
um and you had 22 independent
contractors 22. you could you could come
back with
five i'd start with calling all 22 of
them and going hey what's that what you
doing these days
some work hey i'd start there hey let's
do what we did round two
let's try again all right so a lot of
a lot of a lot of heat coming off of you
when you said don't
at me on the yoga what have you been
attacked for saying that you do yoga oh
my gosh ken are you serious
yes i'm not i'm not playing around oh it
is rooted in middle eastern religions
okay oh so i've i've actually led you
back to america ask america what are
your thoughts on yoga they'll at you
they'll tell you
so it's not stretching and breathing
there's deeper you're telling me there's
more stuff
for me okay originated have you done the
goat yoga
have you because you used to own goats
in your farm days
you used to okay eyes are one of my
favorite little factoids about you and
you're a very impressive woman
you've been my friend for a long time
one of my favorite factoids about you
you're laughing before you even say it
well because i remember the first time i
heard this you had a far you lived on a
farm
in your early single days pre-mat right
yeah and you had some fainting goats and
i thought this was a joke
the only animal i had i had multiple
animals but i don't care about the other
animals i only care about the fainting
goats
so it all comes back to a full circle
for me goat yoga where you do yoga with
a goat on your back listen have you
tried this
i've not tried it though i want to and
just for all my business boutique
listeners right now we're always um
brainstorming fun
experiences for business why not goats
on the stage
fainting goats fought for that in every
meeting and i got shut down because
apparently they use the bathroom on the
stage and on the people and it's just it
actually wouldn't be as cool as it
sounds
have we not been to the circus who is
shutting this down
every time i go to the circus something
happens on the concrete hey
you leave the church i want to see i'm
going to yoga and someone
maybe maybe what if i show up to the
next meeting and say i think there ought
to be feigning goats because i know this
the women would love it
would be the number one thing on the
survey hey it would be because you're
dancing and [ __ ]
these women up and the goats would freak
it would be awesome it would be
experienced it'd be something
all right i fought for it coming to
business boutique this fall ramsay
solutions.com get your ticket there
might be a fainting goat i'm expecting
an email from dave ramsey in t
minus 30 seconds dave loves the idea i
know he does
all right don't move more of your calls
coming right up this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show
america thrilled to have you back
with us i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague christy wright
the phone number to jump in on the
conversation with us is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
christy don't answer this because i
already know the answer have you ever
made a dumb decision with zeros on the
end because you didn't do your research
i have christy has it yes most people
make choices based on feelings or
opinions especially when they're buying
a house
but when it comes to the real estate
market feelings are not your friend
facts are your friend so check your fax
find out
what you can actually afford research
what's trending in home prices
talk to a reputable real estate
professional in your area
never buy a house without the facts
again
go to ramseysolutions.com agent
that's ramseysolutions.comagent and get
an
agent who will help you make smart
decisions
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five
five two two five and i want to talk
about your book well
i was getting ready to say no i'd like
to talk about my book too
no i'm kidding i kid your book launched
monday monday can you believe that
listen people probably don't realize
this
what but when you launch a book when you
launch it for pre-sale and this is this
thing you've been working on
for a long time the content you've
worked on for even longer but the book
at least over a year
oh yeah and you put it out there and
it's this like
it's this exciting but also borderline
terrifying
of like nervousness excitement nerves of
finally putting out there in the world
and then you start to see oh my gosh
it's connecting it's helping people
people are buying it you're hitting your
goals
tell me a little bit about what this
week has been like for you because i
want people to
here's what here's what i want people
here the human being behind the book
you're not just an author and it's a
beautiful cover that the team designed
and all the things but like talk about
like
your heart behind this because i know it
because i get to see it and you've done
hear from you
but i want people to hear not just the
marketing points i want them to hear
from you
because you you have such a um
not i mean passion is the word but it's
more than that like there's this like in
your in your core
this calling to do this i want people to
hear from you as like the person
yeah you know i was the kid that was
terrified
as a teenager that i wouldn't figure out
what i'm supposed to do with my life
really that's the back story a pastor's
kid
and so when you grow up in church and
you hear your dad preaching all the time
to other adults saying hey
do what god's called you to do what god
called you to do and it just becomes
this mantra was it like intimidating of
like this idea of like i have this one
calling what am i supposed to do
100 yeah and so as a teenager like okay
i
i want to do what god's called me to do
what is that how in the crud do you
figure that out it's terrifying
terrifying for adults certainly
terrifying for a teenager so at the root
of all this
i was always that kid who really wanted
to figure it out
and i got direction early on in my life
and pursued it
and i felt that i was called to go into
politics
the very long story when was that when i
was short 16.
okay i felt that i was called into
politics to run for office one day okay
down the line okay and so uh
it's about 31 32 i'm 31 32 realizing
that
this thing that i've been planning for
to the point where we moved in the
neighborhood in the atlanta area
picked a district blah blah blah had all
the plans and i realized that
i didn't want to do that and it freaked
me out 31 32 have been a very
intentional
guy my whole life and i was in a career
crisis
i was like did i miss it have i been i
mean this this is the heart of all this
no for sure and
i was like how could i have been that
far off but i wasn't quite sure what it
was and then when broadcasting kind of
i'm trying to shorten this
when broadcasting becomes a thing i felt
like an imposter i felt like maybe i was
delusional yeah i didn't go to school
for it
yeah i didn't have any experience doing
it and i got a wife and three little
ones under the age of three
so i got responsibilities and so as i
begin to walk it out
and really reset my own life and dive in
that's where the heart of everything i
do comes from is i know that i went
through it
and i felt like i'd blown 32 years of my
life that's not true that's
that's a lie from a pit of hell but i
also wrestled through it got
super clear and figured it out and dove
in and then started on a very long
journey seven and a half years to get to
ramsey solutions
another three years so about 10 years to
step into the dream job
and i know that it can be done and i and
dream job is not about glitz
it's about doing that thing that you
were created to do
god gave you christy talent when you
were born he also gave you a heart
that's unmistakable for certain types of
work you just you think about it you get
juiced
when you're in the middle of it time
stands still and then you have results
that you
personally want to put into the world
and so that's mission and so as i
get began to go through the process for
myself and walk the journey out
it became very clear to me that yes
broadcasting was the work
but the mission was helping people
understand that they were created to
fill a unique role in this world through
their work
that means they're really valuable and
it means they must do it
whether it's a plumber or a professor a
teacher or an astronaut
all work is valuable so that's the heart
behind the book i want to go back to
that moment when you realized you didn't
want to do politics
um because i'd be willing to bet there
are some people there right now
and whether it is um you know they got a
degree in something they realize they
don't want to do it or they've been
doing it for years and they're like i'm
ready for something new
i had a similar moment i um in college
uh was pursuing an advertising degree
and i'm i'm super creative like
that's how my brain works and so i was
like i'm a great writer you're great
with words
yeah i like i thought like i'll come up
with catchy headlines you know
which makes sense and all that and
because i have that that skill and i
really enjoyed it i love the the
challenge of that creative aspect
and senior year of college i went to
university of tennessee senior year we
had to take an advertising ethics class
i've told the story on stage many times
but we watched a documentary about
advertising's effect
on women and people in general but
specifically women and it was like this
this light bulb moment that that is not
what i wanted to do with my life
that i wanted to do something but i
didn't want to contribute to women's low
self-esteem i didn't want to contribute
to that
and not that that's all that advertising
represents by any means but i just the
path i thought i was on was not that
path and it was this moment
of almost devastation feeling like i
have spent
four years a lot of my mom's money in
this college education
towards something that i actually don't
want to do at all
and in the in the sovereignty of god i
use that degree in so many ways in what
i do with teaching women marketing but i
want to i want i'm curious from you when
you had that moment
how did you get yourself out of that
slump or that fear or even the panic of
like oh my gosh i've spent so long
pursuing i moved my family to atlanta
yeah for this path and this is not what
i'm gonna do
how did you break out of that yeah
that's a great question and it was
only in getting really clear on what the
next step was what i was actually
supposed to do and seeing that there was
there was purpose in all of it yeah so
while it was a shift from politics to
broadcasting the reality was nothing
really changed that much
when i actually dove back in and you
just touched on it
so beautiful i realized it was a public
call yeah it was a call to communicate
i thought it was running for office and
giving speeches and writing policy
turns out it is giving speeches but it's
writing books yeah
so it wasn't as big a shift it was
professionally from a sector or from an
industry standpoint
but the actual work itself my talents
didn't shift
you're pulling from all the things you
already had yeah and so then i also now
look back and go hey i ran a business in
that time jeremy breen and i ran i ran a
company together i got so much
experience that helps me
now in what i do just like you mentioned
you use every bit of that work and
experience now
in what you do that's right it's just a
very different mission which is the
result
but the work itself not that different
yeah at all
so getting clear is one of your steps
what's that this is the first step
i gotta get clear what am i supposed to
do right and here's what you
what you got to know when you see talent
passion mission align
i use what i do best is how it looks to
do work i love
to produce results that matter to me it
turns into an arrow when they get in
alignment it points to the marketplace
and here's what's cool and you know this
there's more than one dream job yes
there's more than one career path
yes but what we know is there is a role
you're supposed to fill yes
because of those gifts you have of
talent passion
and a sense of mission yeah and it's
just incredible too because you've taken
your story and
all of this experience and you've put
this in your book that is now on
pre-sale that launched on monday
from paycheck to purpose don't we all
want that
we want purpose the clear path to doing
work you love and it's available for
pre-order
when you go to ramseysolutions.com and
you pre-order his new book
you get over 100 of free bonus items
and you can either even enter a giveaway
for 3 000
and that's totally free text cash to
33789 to enter the giveaway
go to ramseysolutions.com pre-order your
copy get a copy for you get a copy for a
friend that may need it
and help them if they're in that spot of
the fork in the road
breathe life into them show them how to
get clear and actually go
from paycheck to purpose this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome back to the ramsey show thrilled
to have you with us i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague christy wright
today's
scripture of the day comes from matthew
11 29
take my yoke upon you let me teach you
because i am humble and gentle at heart
and you will find rest for your souls
today's quote comes from rob
sultanan people who are crazy enough to
think they can change the world are the
ones
who do i think we're getting a yes and
amen from two crazy people right here i
love that you are trying to change
the love of that that's a great great
quote all right triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number let's go to charlotte north
carolina where fola joins us fola how
can we help
hi thank you for taking my call you bet
what's up i want it
is uh can it be too late to switch
careers
what do you mean by too late
well uh i've been a nurse now for
about 13 years and i am pretty
i'm pretty tired right now oh yeah sure
i've been tired for a while
so i was looking into some other things
uh i tutor and i'm pretty good at that
okay but that that taps into the
side of me the life numbers and things
like that so
i was looking to switch into something
like data management but that would take
some education on my part how much
education would it take
have you looked into that have you
researched it
i have at least a year of
self-study like intense
self-study so uh the technology field
because presumably you could continue
tutoring on the side and make that a
really nice side business sounds like
you're already doing it you enjoy it
but is the technology field something
that you're thinking about this data
management because of the stability and
the career or is it something you really
enjoy
well because i think it'd be something
i'd enjoy
and also because i could potentially
uh merge it with my nursing degree
and work in a healthcare company
fantastic okay so i've got a couple
things for you i want to take on this
idea that you think it's too late
is this because you think your age but
that somebody's not going to hire you is
that what's behind this what's making
you think
is it too late because i already spent
13 years doing nursing
makes me think so okay great let me just
tell you right now
it's not too late you can transition um
one of the
one of the things i want you to do uh in
the next
week i want you to contact bethel tech
betheltech.net
ken coleman we've got a partnership with
them they are training people
for technology jobs with no private
previous
experience you don't have to have a ton
of technical skills they have a
nine-month program
and it's less than fifteen thousand now
that's one example i want you to talk to
them kick the tires
ask them all the questions may not be a
good fit for you but
this year of self-study that you've
already identified that's not too long
and the reality is i know you're tired
as a nurse but if you've got a
clear path forward so you know right now
that technology something that you can
add to your tool belt
and stay in the healthcare world where
you've got a ton of connections 13 years
worth of relationships this is a huge
head start for you
if you can hang on and you can take care
of yourself
i'm gonna have christy talk to you about
some some things that you can do because
you're exhausted
and christy can help you with that but
if you can and i know you can
if you can hang in there long enough to
get qualified christy i know
that she can transition out of that
nursing uh day to day and move into
technology and have a fantastic future
well and it was uh it was what we were
just talking about your career is not
necessarily one thing you do
for four decades like it used to be an
older generation so then you got the the
gold watch and you retire
now it's more of an evolution and and
careers can
can change and they should and and
that's fine it's not too late in fact
it's incredibly normal
and so the one thing i would encourage
you um as ken is talking about what this
looks like of the getting qualified i
just want you to remember that that's a
season
and it won't last forever and so let
that
motivate you to pour yourself into
getting qualified in the season knowing
that the difficulty of staying in
nursing isn't gonna last forever and the
difficulty of getting qualified and
training
is not gonna last forever because when
it's hard because it will be hard to
learn this new thing and to continue to
nursing when your
heart may not be in it anymore that that
is a season and there's light at the end
of the tunnel and when you get to the
other side of the training
you can begin to transition into that
new thing and it will all be worth it
but you're just going to go through a
season of getting qualified that's okay
great advice
foley you got this you absolutely have
this let's just keep looking into this
all the multiple ways to get qualified
and once you pick the right path
you fund your way through it keep the
cash flow going
and then you're going to walk right into
this great future really proud of you
thank you for the call and by the way
don't for a second look back on 13 years
of nursing and say huh
it's just what chris and i were talking
about i kind of wasted some time that's
not true
you are caring for people on the front
lines and uh we salute you follow thank
you and it prepared you for what you're
gonna do next that's
absolutely right all right let's go to
kayla in colorado springs kayla how can
we help
hi yes thank you for taking my call sure
um
i am a systems engineer
and i have been for about three four
years now
been floating in technology um but this
isn't my calling
and i know that it's not my calling this
isn't what i want to do this isn't what
my degree is in
but i'm on baby step two and in order to
pursue the job that i want to pursue i
would take a significant pay cut
how do i juggle the baby steps while
still pursuing what i want to do with
life
i love this question i get it all the
time okay let's just break it down how
much do you have how much debt do you
have
left and then when do you expect to pay
it off currently with your current job
currently
um we have 123 000
left of debt okay um payoff is just
under
two years okay um that's awesome
and and i'm looking at how how can i do
this
do i just sell off the cards in order to
pursue the job that i want
to get rid of the debt faster and sure
okay so let's do
i get it scared i get it but here's the
deal you're in great shape right now
in a job that you're stable in and you
are trucking on this thing so
let's just look at what is it going to
take for you to get qualified do you
know
to change you've already got the degree
is it aligned with your degree and what
do you have to do to get qualified to
change careers
do you know um yeah it's actually pretty
simple i would just have to be hired on
it doesn't require anything so my degree
is in criminal justice
okay um how big of a pay cut how big of
a pay cut would it be
we would be looking at um about 30 to 35
000
a year okay but once we have no debt and
we've got that emergency fund how do you
feel about it let's fast forward how do
you feel about it
if we were there i feel happy you'd
change tomorrow wouldn't you
i would change tomorrow okay i got some
great news kayla listen to me
criminal justice is still gonna be there
in just under two years
i wouldn't put this pressure on you
right now to choose between
paying off debt and doing the work i
love this is how what i teach
and and what ramsey solutions on money
teaches comes together i'm going to tell
you
chill out keep moving forward i'd sell
cars yes
i would try to take the under two years
christy and i try to shave time off of
it because i know
that then i can walk into criminal
justice but you're qualified kayla
here's what i want you to do
i want you to get connected while you're
paying off debt
and make sure that you got every
opportunity that could be available to
you
waiting on you the minute you guys pay
off the debt and get that emergency fund
in a place where you can take the pay
cut
because we've got the third largest
group of net worth millionaires
in this country is teachers that means
they're not they're
the median salary right now in america
for teachers 60 000
so it's not about the paycheck it's
about purpose
and they're moving their lifestyle to be
able to do the thing they love and
that's you kayla you got this it's what
we were just saying about
a season this is a season oh that's it
you're in the season of paying off your
debt that's what i always say this is
what i talk about my book
what's right right now you don't have to
do everything all the time we're gonna
do what's right right now what's right
right now paying off the debt
it's not doesn't mean that dream is
dying it's just not right now right now
what's right right now is paying off the
debt and then when you get debt free
however you get there take an extra job
selling the cars whatever
then what's right oh pursuing that next
step in your career pursuing the job
that you really want but we've just got
to do the right things at the right time
otherwise that dream is going to stress
you out
and we don't want that we want to keep
the joy in it for you but it just comes
down to doing it at the right time
that's it kayla you got this listen
you're at under two years right now you
start selling stuff
getting gazelle intense there's the
extra motivation beyond just getting
debt free it's stepping into the work
that you were created to do keep with it
it's gonna be here before you know it
great word christy on the seasons
i had too much fun i really was so great
it did not feel like it did not feel
like three hours this flew by yeah
very good stuff hey i want to thank our
producer ben hill and our associate
producer kelly daniel
but most of all we want to thank you
america this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you